[Musique]
josh homard au chaud le marron c'est le
fruit du marronnier
et ça ne se mange pas la châtaigne c'est
le fruit du châtaignier et ça ça se
mange la crème de marrons la dinde aux
marrons chauds les marrons
on parle de châtaignes dans tous les cas
ce sont des châtaignes c'est sûr et
certain à 100% on devrait dire crème de
châtaigne dinde aux châtaignes chaud et
châtaignes
en europe on en consomme partout de la
mi octobre jusqu'à noël moelleux ma mère
est native d'ardèche puis la châtaigne
pendant jusque dans les années 50
c'était un revenu agricole non
négligeable
c'était un féculent qui était vraiment
commercialisée à grande échelle
aujourd'hui on encore ça se cultive ça
se vend beaucoup aussi
allez vous avez gentiment accepté de
nous éviter chez vous pour le réveillon
avec plaisir bienvenue dans mon humble
demeure
et puis la baie comme c'est dans vos
habitudes de cuisine et les châtaignes
vous allez me donner quelques conseils
qui est ses seins il ya des choses qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est juste qu'on va
considérer ça dans un premier temps la
châtaigne on peut soit la faire bouillir
la faire blanchir comme onfray blanchir
une pomme de terre à l'eau soit la cuire
au four
moi j'aime bien les cuire au four pour
cobain je pense je suis paresseux un peu
je trouve c'est plus facile la châtaigne
est un des rares fruits qu'on doit
absolument cuir avant de consommer on
prend la châtaigne comme ça et on va
faire une légère incision pourquoi on
fait ça tout simplement parce que si on
faisait pas une entaille dans la
première peau ça ferait un peu comme du
pop corn
ça m'a plu la châtaigne va exploser au
faux après ça on peut l'utiliser comme
on veut
comme vous voyez les châtaignes sont si
elles ont déjà été pré cuites au four
elles ont été nettoyées complètement
après avoir passé une trentaine de
minutes dans le faux on les met
habituellement il faut que 350 pendant
un bon 30 minutes
on veut la dessécher et pouvoir enlever
les deux pots la meilleure façon de
savoir si notre châtaignes elle est
facile à éplucher quand on l'a mise dans
le four c'est que quand on les cales
elle va faire un bruit comme une pinotte
qu'on voudrait et calais on les crasses
comme ça dans nos mains un peu comme si
neuf cuit dur je pas capable d écraser
comme vous et moi faut penser à
quelqu'un qu'on aille hockey comme ça
avec nos châtaignes précuites on cuisine
le classique des classiques mois une
recette que j'aime beaucoup la c'est
bien sûr la dinde aux marrons
donc on met des châtaignes cessa
d'écrire aux châtaignes excusé et j'aime
beaucoup mélanger les châtaignes avec
des pommes là j'ai pris des pancartes le
cd pomme qui résiste bien à la cuisson
et puis après on va se faire une petite
sauce avec un site de glace et des
canneberges pour accompagner le tout ça
va faire noël dans allons-y
je met les oignons auto on va mettre nos
carottes et là il va nous rester à m les
châtaignes et on va vraiment rentrer le
plus possible puis on la laisse cuire
ça dépend de la grosseur de la dengue
mais il faut pas avoir peur de la
laisser un 5/6 heures dans le faux comme
comme la dengue ont fait
traditionnellement ici et avec le reste
des châtaignes
on prépare une crème qui servira à
confectionner quelques desserts ça nous
prend nos châtaignes de l'eau du sucre
et bien sûr une belle gousse de vanille
on cuit une arme à feu doux on ferme les
yeux on est en ardèche parfaite pour
garnir un étage et de crêpes servie en
dessert avec un gâteau et des biscuits
aux châtaignes ses fruits frais sont à
portée surtout d'italie de la mi octobre
jusqu'à noël
sinon on les trouve toute l'année prêtes
à consommer au supermarché dessert près
d'1 2 fours
on en profite pour aller griller des
châtaignes familles directement sur le
feu bon on va s'installer soft et voilà
c'est parti pour les châtaignes
et la boucane c'est vrai qu'on a changé
de bord
écrase les biens à vendre les cas les
side solo je crois que c'est bon un peu
c'est chaud
êtes vous prêt pour la benz allons-y
bien sûr trop chat table à temps
[Musique]
belle tablée belle assiette coutts et on
va souhaiter un bon noël là dessus oui
merci je n'avais que tout le monde
santé
[Musique]